we're gonna make it we gonna make it I
kept my so matter try to take you can
hold me dead thanks so much for coming
to the house you guys are amazing so why
don't you just tell me what you achieved
and then we can go through and unravel
how you did it what for you achieved in
the last sort of three six months in
property yes and since then we've
achieved for rent events essays that's
awesome
yeah so I look financially free now so
that's what we cannot need exit thank
you pretty much yeah and do something
thank you for retraining them yeah we're
looking to build on that and move
forward I'm honestly you the growth of
you as people as well like you've been
on stage like you've really stepped out
of your comfort zone yeah I mean like
the whole the whole aspect of it is to
be uncomfortable you always notice this
is something new you know something new
all the time so yeah we're doing it
thank you and you only got married in
August so thank you massive congrats
congratulations how do you mean I know
you're gonna say you're gonna say you
used your wedding money and she came
back and she's like about your on stages
that come at me so I'm gonna and she's
like so are you gonna do this and
originally she was just gonna sign up to
look like I can't stay at home while
you're living your life in London
we're gonna do it together so um we went
through the payments and stuff and she
was like we need to do yeah we'll just
do it we have to pay the last payment
for the vitamin on Monday and then we
were like that's the only money we had
yeah so if you don't do it now we're
never gonna do it so we just thought
well deal we'll pay that we got her well
we'll figure out so we just don't we did
the rule again managed yeah though I got
married you thought when we when we make
it then we can get married again so
you're gonna say you're gonna have like
a big kind of official wedding day where
you do all the the fancy you know stuff
but you've officially got married
although you didn't have like a fancy
wedding because you used all of your
money on my training hey hey but you
know what you know how that makes me
feel really good because I think that
it's interesting because you've heard me
say this a bank will lend you money for
a wedding but they would have never lent
you money for my program because then I
said that my programs too high-risk
oh so you got the you got a loan to get
married and then use that so oh my
goodness huge white and why waste all
the money so we just have a little right
in and then just yeah invested party was
it worth it
definitely yeah tell me about tell me
about what you experienced beyond the
training on the economy over the last
six months and the people we've met
they're incredible or supportive yeah
yeah well mission together really to
make our lives better and we all
acknowledge that
each other on that way to financial
freedom really the knowledge that we've
got the ends being outstanding like
graduate with the first course that was
a week after we signed up and we were
like so nervous I'm assuming after we
were like this is possible that you can
do this and then just emailing like one
lords had won through me like this is
crazy how is it happening to us it's
very actually because on the way up here
trader Kelly is the right to grantor so
she shoots out all the emails and you
got you got Cockburn speaking to a
landlord a couple of weeks ago didn't ya
months ago even and he said right this
property's gone back bottom level it's
being refitted at the moment it's Penn's
house and Carter just going to be like a
high-end one and they literally just
message today saying the roof it's
finished
yeah we little about the Train and I
don't think we'd be sadly you know like
there's no way learning how to speak to
Lord speak to and negotiating yeah I you
know what's crazy as well is that when I
messaged you a few days ago sent you a
voice now on I think he was Instagram
which I'm living now living together
because I think I saw I saw you share a
story on there and I met I met you at
the the training was it the deal selling
master class and you were really like
doing when I can see you manage owners
that are these guys is so cool and I
sent you a voice note and I was like hey
we should hook up sometime I'm here for
ya and I don't message everybody's
saying that you know we should hook up
some time we should meet however and
then he responded and you were like oh
did you not know I'm actually going to
be at your house in a few days and I had
no idea
he can't know he can't know where no I
had no idea so I was really and then
when you said I'm actually your house I
was just like so cool so it's great to
have a chance to talk to you
so what talk talk to me then the for
rent turns and they rent to serviced
accommodation or might HMO what's the it
was the regulation in Wales around there
so it's not like London because London
there's the whole 90-day rule and so the
only thing you need to look out for then
is the is just that if these apartments
or houses so it so it's just the head
lays the mortgage the basic stuff but in
terms of Licensing and planning
permission there's nothing like that
which is which is cool and whereabouts
in Wales court so we've got onesie yes
she has mental disease the block way we
have the one she owns the whole block
and so yeah so she's like yeah totally
yeah which is a massive advantage once
you can get in with people I do that
because I know so many developers and
they just buy these built build these
big blocks that there's no mortgage
there's no lease issues they're the
whole thing I'm watching you don't need
Benny
they said that soon he's getting with
developers you know you can price though
the the guarantee grants and everything
but it's like yes it's two people coming
together getting the thing that the
developer doesn't want is any
maintenance hassle issues and I think
we've read to rents as well the really
interesting thing is is that people when
they start out on went to rent
especially if they've not properly done
the training is they feel like a bit of
a naughty dirty person trying to
hoodwink someone into letting them
control a property illegally and it's
like is that is totally not what it is
this is a professional service too busy
developers or landlords which is win-win
business you know so as long as you've
got and one of the things that we do on
the on the track on the regiment
revolution that you did like in what one
puts October one if it was on August
when you did the trip Wow a long time
ago is is to write out all the benefits
to the landlord and it's to work out
what for you and every every business
has got different benefits so YouTube as
a power couple will have will have
different levels of skill that you'll be
able to offer people so you know it's
great where do you live yeah Beach so
Beach the airports and I think Wales has
got so much opportunity for property in
general the town work on barriers
actually had the biggest rising house
prices in the whole of the UK but in the
last how long that's incredible yeah so
good even in London as well you know set
a seven percent of properties in London
City uh r1 Airbnb so and even though
there's the 90-day rule because
sometimes what people do is they'll put
it on Airbnb for up to the 90 days and
then they'll just put short term is d
contract tenants in and then they'll
just keep doing that to maximize the
cash flow but but the government are
getting irritated by all the people who
are doing air B&B but it's like well of
course we're going to do that because
profitable because you've made by to let
less profitable with section 24 and now
you now you're upset you know yeah they
are but but that they'll always do that
and I think that right now service
accommodation is a great strategy so
talk to me about the figures that so you
did you see your four properties they
got one interest Cardiff one in Swansea
were about the other two right
sorry got you little touch up here in
there and the line of the psychic I've
gone of the two in this block he said
they're not best to review but if you
couldn't look past it so we looked at
them and he was like we had some review
of it today and they wanted to have for
six months he said but if you were table
through then you can have them so yeah
and we just took that when we that cost
us four thousand to do minor or three is
that is that a true though oh that's oh
right that's not bad and what was that
yeah I've seen you on your Facebook with
your really cheap lovely furniture on a
budget so what did that three thousand
what was the breakdown of that while the
costing yeah was that like all the
furniture all was that three-month three
weeks three ranks was it did you know
what negotiating or on my videos where
I've shown people me getting rent two
minutes people almost don't believe they
like what landlord would give you a free
period of read what landlord would not
make you pay a deposit and it's like
well they're all unloads out there yeah
there are some landlords they've got and
the things going on like this sorry
person yeah he that's what the lawyer
said to us this is just my back my back
to go in yeah yeah yeah - it's a block
of five so we've got three moment and
then he said the other two might be
moving out February marks we can help
down the side if you want them it should
be really good because then yeah it's
advantageous actually because we've got
it all on one advertisement online yeah
bookings can stay like yeah most like 14
people I mean we've got a booking it's
handy having three in one block because
also if you if you if you've got some
double booking or anything it's just
amazed there's a lot of advantages sir
amongst the four went to rent what's
your I don't know it very month-to-month
because if it's a quiet month it'll be
less if it's a really good but if it
could be crazy by averaged over the year
what's your profit each month when more
than happy taking just an S Jeff in the
two thousand and that was our fine and
financial freedom fear and anything over
that now would be permanent one man yeah
with this one once it's like to all of
those documents isn't it that's a place
that you can that we've done that we
know so we're just full-time property
which is like it's really like where the
dream or like the only hint we've only
got four properties it might imagine and
we actually probably lure
so it's completely passive now I said
that mm or Everest maybe just over
around 2000 that is actually without you
doing anything that's cool so what the
cleanest yeah so yeah it's very good he
was homeless
he said he sent me a message on facebook
didn't e ya sayin oh hi hope you a lot
of blood I was like this is random so I
wonder if that means like I've been
homeless for eight months living on the
streets like on drugs crazy life well we
didn't have a clue we were just living
our life classic this this is not okay
to pick him up he stayed with us on the
bed so it's mild and these games like on
track now so he is our cleaner so we
starting with company and I clean up
which is amazing for him and I wanted to
get in Pittsburgh and so he's gonna take
out more more I think I like not essays
like clearly more a favorite holiday
I know it's young sad isn't it but
because the other than over Swansea
essay we found it tough finding a
cleaner that Acuras yeah we're suited to
serve as a combination down there and
ones that wouldn't cost an arm and a leg
and things like that so having a cleaner
on site that's sort of its built now
with it's just like developed into how
we're gonna structure up is next year so
we're gonna have like a mother company
with other companies underneath and then
things like the cleaners the maintenance
will feed and feed and so yeah as long
as it's better coming in house yeah
- so yeah so he's he's like on board he
wants to get some cookies in yeah yeah
she's like why are you shy
put yourself out there that is amazing
it's great that you've managed to use
your business to actually help bring
employment - or self-employment butts
but - what - one of your family members
who was really in need at so custom
story also has got experience with a
chair moves and how it feels being
homeless and the system basically yeah
and how it does felt like we were stuck
with it like it sucks
yeah the system just fails people so
much what do you mean by that so he was
in prison wasn't he and then he came out
of prison there's just no there's no
support people that had come out of
prison so he had no choice but to speak
on the streets as soon as he came out of
prison so yeah so then that's just how
it builds but even when you're in a
situation where you're going to lose
your house and stuff like that like is
no support - maybe personal mental HMO
or whatever just to try and help people
because I think it's tough it's tough
for people to sort of survive when
you're on minimum wage oh yeah it is
well cost of living has gone up a lot
but salaries haven't yes that's what I
don't like about it yes that's why we
like sorry because we were like how are
we ever going to be a
how much our lives William minimum wage
and if you want kids
yeah we I thought we wrecked it didn't
ya to start with and we were literally
just existing because we were getting
paid and then all our bills would come
out and then we're no motor to live off
to you're like right I'm not doing this
and then we went out traveling the enemy
and we went into Australia a man created
their crazy wages yeah double what you
are here for like minimum wage we were
like I want on this is amazing so we
started hustling it's like Oh what about
60 hour weeks yeah love the money money
and then I got quiet and I was just like
looking at the people I was working in
restaurants and all these people come in
and spend just as much as I was in it
just eating out every week you know it's
like what do you do it's about speaking
to them ERISA what do you do and let
your neighbor investors and they will
have the time in an amazing country to
be able to go and do whatever they
wanted and so I thought I need to learn
how to get passive income yeah so then I
started googling and yeah that's when I
found you and other books and things
like that's like reading and we came
home had nowhere to live again so back
to 60 hours we had to lay him on saved
six thousand pounds that gone by hat and
we did the help to buy exactly what we
write we knew about you and we came back
as like families oh my god why are we
done
[Music]
oh my god and so now we're just trying
to get out of that pickle as well but
yeah we're gonna write solicit I mean
how did you go it's so interesting
because I mean I think you wrote I think
that the system is created for people to
be poor and I think it's because if
you're if you're wealthy then the
government cannot control you and help
to buy scheme is about control it's
completely about control so they will
suck you into a scheme and then suddenly
they tell you exactly what to buy and it
has to be in the building has to do this
and you can only save this much in a
nice zone and it's just totally there
you know the whole system is like work
really hard at school and then get a job
for life which by the way doesn't exist
you know the whole the whole thing is so
flawed and sometimes that can lead to
serious problems at you've talked about
your brother who is literally on the on
the streets which is terrible and
homelessness is on the rise but then
also as well so a lot of people are just
almost kept in that just comfortable
enough stage you know where it doesn't
hurt bad enough for them to say actually
you know what I'm gonna get trained I'm
gonna get educated I'm gonna do
something different but at the same time
you know they're just they're in this
rat race it is but like how something
from fit from from in that you know trap
of being a slave to a job working 60
hours a week with very little money to
then even just a mindset like what how
did you cuz I think it's a much how did
you go from that to then financially
free and then you guys aren't rich that
making loads of money but but you're
making a couple grand a month and it's
passive which is which is life-changing
how did that happen I mean you have just
gotta step back from your life and what
you've got going on because it can't
just continue and you just think it you
just not thinking about your future
you're just trying to get one day at a
time
yeah it was traveling so we might
attract them for a year we had like like
Chanel said we had a good job
well paid jobs and then we came home and
we were like in like 70 pounds an hour
this is not okay so we got we've gotten
in the job each in a tape repair shop
delivering pizzas Saturday nights and
Friday nights which was it wasn't too
bad but we were like this is my life
like new hotness that there's Putman
little pizza for the backs of our lives
leave our kids at home that's what it
wasn't it yeah just thinking actually
how their life you want to live
it isn't matching up to what we're doing
right now when something needs to change
because I'm not we would wake up 6:13
leave a house at 7:30 in the morning
we wouldn't be home till half past 11:00
at night because we're going to one job
to the other mm-hmm so there's no way
you can just maintain this for another
40 50 years some of stadiums but you
know they're doing this last we were
just like no time to do anything did we
we didn't literally like see friends and
family feel like 300 just like they were
we didn't really care because we had a
name a goal we knew we need to I have
but obviously the goal was a bit really
the vision like Newton's we were in
desperation I think it's because we had
each other as well like we'd way Pakman
we don't really watch ten in any way but
you don't like your videos on like okay
wasn't it yeah and then just breezing
the ball I think you carried it a lot
because you I'm like quite chilling be
like oh let's watch a film you know we
can like why would wait or not we don't
preserve watching film we'd never get
educated so I think it's just carried
each other along wasn't there a lot and
just pushing when you came to I mean
it's so interesting because it's very
easy in the situation like that to
almost become a victim of society and to
say you know what because I'll say the
system sucks the system's designed to be
to make people poor but that's not me
saying that as a victim that's not me
saying so so it's so easy to become a
victim but what you what you guys have
done is you've become like a Victoire
you know through it and you've
acknowledged it I mean it was was was
the only point at the crash course where
did I ever say anything that was like a
offended you or something it's just like
what cuz I mean I'm
or was it just like Noah this is so
right every time you meet some people
just need to be spoken to like that and
95% some people are just like what are
you doing
yes cuz cuz off cuz I'll speak very
direct you know this year's are how
broke people think this is how rich
people think there's other people get
offended by that but I mean I think it's
really amazing
you know what you've achieved what's
been the hardest thing about building up
your internet portfolio for me it was in
the beginning so we went on the event of
revolution in August because you gotta
marry it we were like evil acts and they
were just like like just in petaluma
period won't wait so how many few weeks
off and then just like the whole thing
of like not feel that not getting
anywhere and as soon as we had people
reply to us and like oh my gosh this is
fine we can do this so with the fact of
like taking a few weeks for people to to
come back to come back to you in
language as soon as people started
applying taxing the like it getting it
can be really easy to - fall at the
first hurdle yeah what from the time
from the first crash course to actually
securing the deals have seen the money
coming in it's tough like because you
don't know what they're actually wanna
be on in and I've been that's probably
that that's the window where people will
give up again oh no I can't do it yeah
whatever
when we first started we thought oh
we're going to be financially free in
few weeks because that's that's not
really I know people do that people come
in a week that I'm not financially free
but it's like I mean I can do it in a
week because I've been in the industry
over a decade but really realistically
from a standing start
without any knowledge you're not going
to come to the crash
we finally free it's just unrealistic
and that's what we generally speaking
yes I give it a year if you consistently
put seven or eight hours a week
consistently for a year and how you can
do it faster I mean you guys have done
it I've done it sooner than that but it
is I guess it can be I mean did you ever
feel like giving up at any point it
probably took us about three months to
actually find direction yeah think about
actually what do we what do we want to
achieve so we knew them we wanted to and
start acquiring assets but to acquire
assets we weren't in a position to start
just buying houses like so we needed
cash flow so we broke that down and what
what can we what achieves the highest
cash flow so we were like essays HMOs
super eggs so I'm we were like okay well
go for that and the only way the entry
entry point but that would have been
wrecked event because we didn't have a
lot of money to start off with so yeah
that's where we are right now we've
completed that phase of our business and
now we're moving on to acquiring assets
which will be again getting impacted
yeah that's really really good it's just
like you guys are the perfect case
studies where like because we're you are
because because you know you came you
didn't have much violence is the small
amount that you did have you you you you
put above a wedding I mean talk about
priorities
[Music]
yeah yeah I mean you can do both but if
you have a choice between one or the
other hands down I put it into my
property investment business into my
education hounds down because then you
have a great wedding day but a miserable
marriage because you're both working six
days a week they got married and have
loads of debt and then they're working
six there's no point have you added me
opposition from friends family crazy
funny friend and she's like we just like
we can take the rest how it goes roughly
I'm 25 real commitments we just saw
that's yeah that's one thing as well
that we had on our side and not everyone
is in the same situation is that okay
we're young with no commitments really
mm-hmm
if you've got like if you've got lots of
you know kids and you've got a mortgage
and you've got a really a high-paid job
it can actually be harder than when you
in situation when you've got no money
but you have got the courage and they I
guess you've got commitment to each
other and you had jobs when did you quit
your jobs so I was off on the step one
we went to the crash cause I had an
operation and I just didn't wanna go
back because I was just full of anxiety
oh just the thought of every day was
just like crippling yeah
of what it was I was working for me to
media and it's like fingers fingers
fingers fingers and it's like that
manager will be down with managing that
managers down and we were at the bottom
of the bow we were the ones that got
blamed for absolutely everything wrong
with the figures and everything like
that because it all stemmed from so yes
yeah and so yeah we got it and you at
the crash course and you just think you
figure we did you have the operation
just before and what was people with
y'all so when it's it's actually crazy
because it's similar to something that
my mom died from and it's my ovaries
basically so yeah I got pretty sick from
that when I was younger and yeah so
really nasty bathroom burning inside me
was out to make sure that I don't leave
my leave my children early and yeah
pretty much
and you think that that's helped in a
way as motivation within the property
business what a million was Sam I mean I
was 13 a single child only child my mom
died it was just like everything that I
am new life which literally lived on
looks like that we went in just like it
was all just gone so yeah I was just
like I don't I don't want that to happen
for my children yeah and when did you do
when did you two meet okay so like five
years ago as the year I got married I
was a magical year of love then and and
when you got when you got together and
stuff and started brought in life
together
did you did you ever think that you were
gonna be business people and successful
yeah yeah no you don't you just don't
think it's crazy how you like to change
in even a matter of months at six months
where when money my money told me six
months ago you're going to be fun
together like go away you're lyin yeah
because you just think this is
impossible it's not yeah it can't be
possible
so how would you say that the property
business as you put your closer together
yeah we know each other a lot of we yeah
I think we we blend well because I'm
very whole that has to be words figures
need to be right and everything she's
very and I'm pessimistic she's like and
I also feel a little bit like from from
observation because I've spent time we
have senior programs so so you're very
facts figures you know kind of
responsible the responsible like where
where was you know Kelly you're very
people person you know you can win
people over you can negotiate a good
deal so so I think so I think I can see
why you're very successful together and
it's just so great you know seen you do
while getting to know you
what's the what's the plans for the
future that you're making a couple grand
a month you've got four into rent so
you've got the scale are you gonna scale
that usually you're gonna talk stop line
assets you've just you just did the deal
selling masterclass so now if you see in
properties that maybe you can't quite
afford to get or it's out of your patch
I will always recommend selling them to
other people and I think we've just
helps you with the website and stuff
which I'm gonna totally leave in the
description so people can find you and
check you out so talk to me about the
assets that you wanted to build
yourselves so we've actually Kelly's got
an a disabled cousin so we're looking
into the assisted living sector and
because we know that they're struggling
in any way
to have those type of properties and
properties that are actually suited to
them so one aspect of our of our
business is going to be its HMOs
essentially yeah but it's for those
vulnerable people out there that need it
and yeah to be able to address the
properties and the way that they like it
so it'll be a bit of BRR
it's combining strategies on yes so boy
you know what people are us I'm so glad
you said that because people sinto say
to me what would you recommend this
strategy this strategy this it's like to
be honest you've got to sometimes just
learn them all and then go and help
people solve their property problems and
being open and holding the strategies of
your sleeve and combining strategies you
know like assisted living we've got a
lot of that probably is not assisted
living HMO but you can combine that with
by refurbish refinance buy it turn into
HTML then we find out set so it's like a
verb property we have an HMO in the
middle you know each dually yeah a lease
option agreement have an option by piece
of land or option but then develop it
and then you combine development with
option you know so and I think I mean
that's morning thick great things about
the the Academy which is that you learn
all the strategies because we knew to
$12 we have to place our income so
events for Adsense accommodation so that
was in August and then only yeah so
we're done with that now we've got cash
flow and then the next stage was steal
sorted and then we had the deal selling
mastery work this is perfect
therapy and in all of the route have you
done infinite returns yet you just you
just David it's all a blur yeah why do
you keep going to the crash courses
philosophy comes out of under time how
do you make a lot if you do changes your
perception when people say to me you
know are some movie you definitely gonna
be at the crash course as I probably
will be but listen don't come for me
come for you yeah thanks the last of it
we pulled you onstage do it what's the
worst I always say look at the best case
worst case like the case if the worst
case is not that bad just do it if the
worst case is I'm gonna wind up bankrupt
there okay maybe not but if the worst
case is I'm gonna look really stupid
or I'm gonna get told no by it like when
you ring it up landlord's enjoyed you
right depends what's the worst thing
that you know the worst thing is that
they'll just say oh I fugue are not
interested okay well you know if there's
no wound it what's the problem just pick
up the phone and the reason that our
course is is that we get people to
sometimes do crazy stuff as soon as
people say oh they made me high-five
someone it's like because we want to
create an atmosphere and energy whereby
you're prepared to do whatever it takes
and you're prepared to be uncomfortable
and then when we start asking you to
make phone calls to agents and stuff and
and that's why our training gets the
best results because you're in that
environment and actually doing it you
know what will cheer like
yeah this is just that environment that
we just have been in I always love it
when it's easy I love it when I see you
at crash course it's tough
no I'm like Samarin Kelly yes no I love
it I think it's great it's like a drug
almost yeah and then and some people
might not quite get that some people
might just you know what I'm just about
take notes gather the knowledge and
that's fine but then some fit for me
anyway I just love being in the van when
people we want you to succeed and what
when you you know isolations never a
good place you know and especially when
you've got family and friends which
generally people do have saying be
careful you know yeah that's how I say
that I just see it like you're just like
a bit of a crazy desperate to try and
make it but hey proof of the pudding and
this is what normally happens to starts
off would be careful then it's okay well
let's just say let's wait and see so now
it's probably will see stage I'm making
a couple grand with full timing property
it's going okay we'll see let's see what
happens after we know we finished all
this breaks this stuff and and and then
when you go and start buying properties
and you established it's been three or
four years then it's a you've changed
yeah did you have that don't change but
the power point is you want to change
we've been just trained to think a
certain way to do same things and it's
like a whole 20 20 or whatever years of
undoing what we've just been taught and
the way the way of living to go to work
ya know because I think that life is
such a wonderful thing but if you are so
wrapped up in it in in having in a rat
race you know and I am NOT anti-jobs
like you know I employ a lot of people I
employ myself unemployed on my own
payroll not anti-jobs while I'm auntie
is having to go to work and dreading it
still out when you came to Kruskal she's
out you were just dreading that we
should not no one should have to go
through that so much is just increasing
so much as an amount of people suffering
from mental happiness and I honestly
believe it's from the whole system yeah
from this whole life that we were made
to live and that's what we're just like
that estates to have because we were in
the back race renting the property we
took a step out and we were like the
other side of the world the way they're
paid properly in Australia they actually
live life yeah but they do work but they
I mean the sun's probably a part of it
as well yeah
yeah there's some some helps but then if
you've got if you've got money there you
can then every winter you go to Spain or
go to travel so travel is a big part of
your life fantastic fantastic and I know
I think you're right I think that it's
not healthy for the for the brain to
never be able to take a holiday and
that's why it's funny because you know
my upbringing I grew up you know very
working-class I wouldn't say really poor
anything's too crazy but there was times
single-mom we didn't have enough money
for carpets in the house so that sort of
being there and it's all relative and
part of my mission with the training is
to help people who have been in a
situation like I've been in and and it's
yes and most people say because I
because I sometimes it's for me it's a
scary and responsible filled position to
be in when you've got people like you
guys coming to the crash course and
saying you know what we're absolutely
skin may be struggling meant that I
don't know but and saying oh and a bank
loan that we're about to get married
with you know what we're gonna it's like
I could really ruin your life right it
is you know so that's scary but then I
can look at the stats and see well look
these are the people have been paid for
the training that I know statistically
we have a very high success rate I know
statistically we have a very high
satisfaction rate although as scary as
it is is people like you guys that keep
me going
you know so thank you for you know for
believing in yourselves for believing in
in the training and and for putting the
work in because and when I say it's
people who's always so cheesy but but I
say your success is my oxygen it is what
keeps me going
we wear even a small as we are I went
always trying to help people as wide you
mean this is it's just it's good feeling
isn't it yeah I know obviously we got
people coming up to us and were like
they're in common with where they want
to live and stuff and their situation at
home changes and were like oh yeah move
the man yeah it is
well you've it helped your brother and
and the rippling effect of that cuz
you'll help people and they're now help
people in you know
so timidly we just want to leave the
world better than we found it thank you
so much honestly well I'm really
grateful and I'm really excited to be
friends as well as your business trainer
and congrats on your success so much you
can't hold me down
you can't hold me down you you you you
you can't hold me down